okay great thank you john i'm up to
speed
okay how are you feeling no i'm
uh i'm nervous yeah
this is 22 year old tawanda mucheowa
he's about to do something he's never
done before
it's my first time to be on an interview
there is a story the zimbabwean needs to
tell
he says he survived a brutal ordeal
and fears for his very existence my
abductors my captors told me that
they would keep on coming after me and
they say that if i say a weight about my
abduction as i'm doing right now
if i tell the world about my hotel
they were going to come after me and the
next thing i was going to see
is um is my coffin
the ordeal began on the 30th of july
when the university student made a trip
to the local hardware shop
in the city of bulawayo but machewa and
his companions
appeared to have been followed by a
group of men
operating from at least five vehicles
and they grabbed him as they waited
outside the shop
the incident was recorded on cctv
they bundled me up you know just like i
was a people like
they just picked me up like i was that
lighting
then they drove from maybe for about 400
meters 500 meters
then they said we are now
changing you to another car
mucheawa believes these men are state
security agents
who've been accused of abducting dozens
of government critics over the past few
years
the 22 year old says he doesn't know why
he was taken
although he was associated with the
opposition mdc
party these guys there
they have a gun the gun is pointed at me
and one of the guys
was sitting on my stomach
the other one was sitting on my head
then there's a moment that i started
complaining that you know i can't
breathe
one of the guys had to punch me hard and
said
you are not george floyd and this is
zimbabwe
not america and anyways we don't want
you to breathe
[Music]
the president of zimbabwe emerson
managua
was elected in 2017 on the promise of
reform
but his critics accuse him of ruling
like a dictator
independent journalists like hopewell
chinono
have been arrested after running stories
on alleged government corruption
amucheawa says his captors wanted
information on his
uncle mudaduzi matutu he's the editor
of the zim live news site and currently
in hiding
they wanted to know about him and they
wanted to know his sources of
information where does he get
information
where does his newspaper get his funding
through him they were saying i
he had been also recruited to
become part of the cia you know it was
so ridiculous
[Music]
the university student says he was
driven to a clearing
outside the city it marked the beginning
he alleges
of three days of mental and physical
torture
i got off the car
then they said kneel down
then they said kneel down and
one of the guys pointed an ak-47
in my head then they said
make your last prayer
say your last words before we kill you
you know i
it's okay take your time take your time
yeah
and i accepted my own death i was really
convinced that
i was not going to die then one of the
guys then said
after my my long prayer rather
he then said we are not going to kill
you now
we must torture you first
[Music]
machewa claims he was strung up on a
v-shaped tree
and his back and buttocks were flailed
with sticks
when he was untied he says his captors
proceeded
to sexually humiliate him
they then did something which
i still sometimes not
comfortable to talk about you know
sometimes you are the one who is abused
and
at the end of the day you are the one we
have to
live with the shame
he was taken to a farmhouse where the
interrogation
and the interrogation techniques
continued
but he claims a number of his captors
wanted to speed things up
at some point they received a call i
believe it was from one of their bosses
and they are discussing and they are
saying oh tawanda is only 22 years old
we should get rid of him just imagine if
he
get to 30 he will give us a lot of
problems so we should just get rid of
him
now and forever this document
may have saved the student's life it's a
court order
obtained by this human rights lawyer
requiring the zimbabwean police to find
machiawa
and present him in court within 72 hours
with as much as we knew that has been
taken by the police and state security
agents
they you know they pretended to
have no knowledge about it you know and
we knew that something was alright
they have to be compelled by a
hypothetical to bring
back to them unfortunately they did so
the 22 year old says he was loaded into
a car
and driven back to bulawayo when the
vehicle was stopped at police
checkpoints
machewa says his captors identified
themselves
as ferrets the name of a shadowy police
unit
that's been implicated in civilian
abductions
when you go to police checkpoints you
you you think
maybe this is where i'm going to watch
to get help
but you know these people they just say
ferret
and they pass at some points they would
harass the police harass the soldiers
and in the road and you know
you would wonder you know who are these
people with so much power
he says they dumped him on the outskirts
of the city and issued a series of
threats
tell people what happened or seek
treatment at a hospital
and will kill you but the 22 year old
didn't have a choice
his body was battered and hospital
records show
his kidneys were barely functioning what
happened to me in weeds i feel sometimes
is doing injustice
you know the pain was just so intense
and i you know you know
you would just be wishing that it was
better if i had
died or you know
the issue is clearly sensitive for the
zimbabwean government
this student leader in red was beaten
and arrested
when he held a meeting in support of the
22 year old student
the authorities did not respond to our
inquiries
although they have accused people of
faking abductions in return for western
funds in the past
no it's not the way that i thought
things would
[Music]
would go tawanda mucheowa has gone into
hiding
nursing wounds both physical and
psychological
that he may never recover from john
sparks
sky news